well welcome everyone um thank you all
for coming out to the barnes and noble
at bu tonight
new york times best-selling author of
bringing down the house joins us to talk
about his newest release
rig the true story of an ivy league kid
who changed the world of oil from wall
street to dubai which debuted on several
bestseller lists
a self-described method writer ben
mesrick never intended to write a book
about oil
as he states in his author's note the
stories that turned him on usually
involved brilliant young kids pulling
off incredible schemes
wads of cash strapped to backs ferraris
and long-legged models and locales so
exotic
that i need the internet to help me find
them on a map quote
but a chance meeting with a harvard
business school student named john
dagostino
led to a story he couldn't resist rigged
is a story of the merck exchange hotel
palaces in dubai
yachts with girls flown in by saudi
sheiks and dangerous back alley dealings
named people magazine's sexiest author
ben mesrick has written
nine books including the bestsellers
bringing down the house
and ugly americans in fact bringing down
the house was the basis for the 2008
kevin spacey movie 21
that was filmed here at bu ben mesrick
is a columnist for stuff magazine
boston and boston common as well as a
contributor to the uk magazine flush
please welcome ben mesrick
thank you very much thanks and if you're
wondering about the people magazine
sexiest man thing it's uh
not that hard a competition if you look
at the other authors that i was
competing against it wasn't
that rough but um rather than do a
reading i thought i was just going to
tell you about
how i got to here how i got to writing
rigged
which is kind of a departure for me
because it's kind of political and
serious and i usually write
pretty non-serious stuff um but uh i
never set out to be a non-fiction writer
i
i never liked non-fiction i always hated
non-fiction i used to
watch really bad television and i was a
into people magazine and
us weekly and stuff like that and when i
sat down i knew i wanted to be a writer
but i didn't know what kind of writer i
wanted to be so i actually um graduated
from harvard and i locked myself in an
apartment on
marlborough street in back bay and i
just started writing and i wrote and i
wrote and i wrote
and i wrote about nine novels in about a
year and a half
and they were all really bad they were
deep dark
trashy novels that took place in bars in
new york city because at the time i was
reading a lot of brady cineless and jay
mcinerney and i thought
that's the kind of books you know people
read and it really wasn't true and i was
sending them out and getting rejected
and getting rejected and i got about
190 rejection slips in a period of two
years
rejected by everybody in new york i was
even rejected by a janitor once
because i sent a manuscript to an editor
who was no longer working at a
publishing house
and it ended up in the garbage and the
janitor took it out and read it and then
rejected me
so it shows you where i was going and i
kept writing and writing and finally an
editor at random house took pity on me
and he called me up and he said you know
i'm not gonna publish anything you've
written
but uh i want you to go read john
grisham and then come back to me in a
year
so i went home and i read john grisham
and i read michael crichton and i read
robert ludlum and i read all the
thrillers i could find and i thought
okay
i could try and write a thriller i could
probably do this and this was sort of
the dawn of er
er was really hot so i thought i'll
write a medical thriller
so i wrote a book that turned into my
first book and it was called threshold
and i'm sure none of you ever heard of
it don't worry about that
but it was you know a medical thriller
my dad helped me out because he was a
doctor so i got all my information from
him
it was about an evil scientist and
planning genetic diseases in people
and it was you know it didn't do that
well but it was good enough to get me a
second book
which was a book called reaper which
none of you heard of that one either
and uh that was about a computer virus
that makes the jump to the biological
world and people
start getting sick from their television
sets and i came up with this idea while
watching oprah
actually um i can say that because the
odds of me getting on oprah are really
small so
um so that that idea was sort of just
trashy enough to catch the attention of
hollywood
and that actually became a tv movie
called fatal error
which still airs on the sci-fi channel
at about
two in the morning and if you see it you
should turn the channel because it stars
antonio sabato jr
if you remember him he was a underwear
model from melrose place and calvin
klein
and he plays a surgeon which was really
believable
casting and uh i remember watching the
movie with my dad who was a doctor
and uh in the middle of it you know
antonio junior leans over this
patient's chest and he goes we've got a
subdural hematoma
and my dad turns me and goes you know
that's in the head right
so that was the level of that movie and
i learned sort of the first rule of
hollywood which is that
the writer ranks just below the caterer
because uh even at the end of the movie
i couldn't get into the wrap party
and i actually had to only get in as
antonio sebato junior's
a part of his entourage so you know it
shows you where the writer ranks in
hollywood
i went on from there and i caught the
attention of the x-files
and they had seen fatal error and i
guess they liked it so they asked me to
come write for the x-files
but i didn't want to move to la because
i at the time i didn't know how to drive
um because you're in boston you don't
really know have to know how to drive
and uh my wife is sitting there she'd
tell you i still don't know how to drive
but i think i'm much better now
but anyways i i said i don't want to
move there but i'll write a book
starring mulder and scully so they said
okay go ahead so i wrote an x-files
novel um starring mulder and scully and
it
takes place mostly in thailand which i
had never been to and i actually just
used a guidebook
to write all the thailand scenes and it
was a about a skin transplant gone bad
and all these people were you know
getting killed by this guy who had
gotten a skin transplant from a murderer
so mulder and scully are investigating
the skin and where it came from
and the book was called skin so it shows
you how creative i am and uh
went on from there and i was really just
looking for another thriller idea
and uh i had no intention of doing
non-fiction and i used to hang out at a
bar called crossroads which a lot of you
probably know crossroads which is
right basically down the street and
there were these mit kids who hung out
there
and they were your regular mit kids i
mean they look like math science guys
and
there was nothing remarkable about them
except for they had tons of money
and it was always in hundred dollar
bills and in boston you really don't see
that many hundred dollar bills
like you know you go to new york you see
hundred dollar bills you go to vegas you
see lots of hundred dollar bills
but in boston you hardly ever see
hundred dollar bills so i went up to the
main guy who in the book i called kevin
lewis
and in the real life his name is jeff ma
now there's a big movie coming out he
wants me to start using his real name
so it's jeff ma um and uh i said jeff
why
why do you have so much money and he
said well come over my house i want to
show you something
so i go over to his apartment and he's
in south end and i go there and he
points to his laundry closet
and i open the closet door and stacked
above his laundry with something like
150
000 in banded stacks of hundred dollar
bills
and immediately i assume he's got to be
a drug dealer but he was this geeky math
guy
there's no way this kid was a drug
dealer so i asked him about it and he
said well come to vegas with me
and so two days later i flew to vegas
with jeff
and there were about five of his friends
with him everybody sat in different
seats
pretended they didn't know each other
when we landed in vegas there was this
limo waiting and this
uniform limo driver comes over and says
mr kevin lewis i have your car
and of course his name wasn't kevin
lewis so immediately i knew something
interesting was going on
and we go to the hard rock and we check
into this massive mega
you know vip suite and we had a butler
we didn't even know what to do with a
butler but we had a butler
and we check in there and all the other
mit kids come into the room and they
just pull money out from under their
clothes
and they had a million dollars in cash
on them that they had flown
america west from boston to vegas
carried it on their body and they
stacked it up
on the table in the middle of the room
and said we're the mit blackjack team
and at the time there had never been
anything written about the mit blackjack
team
i kind of had heard of it but i thought
it was basically this math class at mit
where people
practice blackjack or something and they
told me that basically it had been going
on
at mit for 25 years and it had been
handed down from group of students to
group of students i mean there might be
people in here
who've played on the mit blackjack team
and each new group of students you know
would train the next one
and they had a bankroll that would also
travel from year to year
and it was a million dollar bankroll and
they would use that to beat blackjack
and they had won this group that i was
writing about had run be one between
three and six million dollars
um not positive where it landed
somewhere around five million dollars
probably
in a period of two and a half years and
i was blown away by this because i had
been writing these trashy thrillers for
the past two years
and suddenly this was a true story that
was better than any of the stuff i was
coming up with on my own
so i just started following the mit
blackjack team and i started going every
weekend
and i became the money carrier because i
wasn't good enough at math to actually
count cards
so i would strap all the money to my
body it turns out you can carry about a
quarter million dollars under your
clothes pretty easily
and uh you know it's not illegal to
carry your own money but if you get
caught
at logan airport with a quarter million
dollars on you it looks really weird
and yeah you end up in a in a cell
underneath the airport actually
handcuffed
and the dea comes in and the irs comes
in and i don't have to tell you how i
know that but i know that and
you spend some time trying to prove that
it's your money so anyways
basically i started following and a lot
of you probably read bringing down the
house so you know the system where
they'd spread six to ten college kids
out across the casino
one kid sitting at each table and he
would keep track of the cards
and when the cards got good which meant
there were more tens jack kings or
queens or aces in the deck
they would signal the guy called the big
player who's acting like a rich drunk
high roller
and he would walk up to the table and
bet ten thousand dollars a hand
then he'd get the signal it's no longer
good and he would keep walking so in
that way big money was only being placed
down
on good decks and it worked really well
because the casinos couldn't see what
was going on normally it's very easy to
catch a card counter
because you sit there at the table and
you watch the cards and then you double
your bet you triple your bet
the casino sees you doing it there's
nothing illegal about it but they frown
upon it and they'll quickly come and
throw you out or worse um but the mit
team would use this big player system
and they they were doing it very well
they would actually use the casino
stereotypes against them
because the casinos have this view of
what a high roller is supposed to look
like
and if a guy who looks like me comes
into a casino a white guy with glasses
from boston and i come in with a million
dollars it looks really strange
but if an asian kid or a persian kid
comes into a casino
with a million dollars they look like a
high roller so the mit team would
recruit as many asians and persians as
they could which was actually quite easy
to do at mit
and also it turns out that women can get
away with card counting forever
because the casinos don't believe women
can do math
and i interviewed one girl who was an
attractive blonde
who would wear a tennis outfit and she'd
carry a tennis racket and she'd sit at
the blackjack table
and she'd pretend that her husband was
still playing tennis and she was so
bored
and she was an applied economics major
at mit but the assumption was she was a
dumb blonde and she could card count
right in front of everybody and never
get caught
and it also turns out that if there's an
attractive woman in a low-cut outfit
at a casino all of those thousands of
cameras are actually trained on her
and i was actually in the venetian
security booth once and all those
screens
they showed a woman walking through the
casino and sitting down and i said oh is
she going to rob the place
they're like no we just get bored back
here so it's a very sort of you know odd
system but they watch women so the mit
team
would recruit as many women as they
could and this was actually much harder
for these guys to do
if you knew these guys you'd know what i
was saying but they would actually end
up hiring women they would hire
strippers to sit at the table as a
distractor to keep the cameras on the
woman and they'd be betting ten thousand
dollars a hand
or they would also sit at tables where
there were real high rollers like
celebrities because if there's a
celebrity at your table even if he's
only betting a hundred dollars a hand
the cameras are all on him and you can
be sitting here betting ten thousand
dollars and nobody cares
and so they've played with all of the
celebrities it's funny as we made the
movie
i mean we had played with kevin spacey
before we knew kevin spacey and people
like
you know lawrence fishburne had been
sitting at the table before but they had
no idea that mit kids were sitting with
them
so that was kind of cool but anyways
that was that system and that was that
book
now rigged you know which is the book
the new one that's out now um
it came about basically after bringing
down the house came out i knew this kid
who had gone to harvard business school
and uh his real name is john dagistino
and he actually let me put his real name
in the beginning of the book
but not in the whole book and i'll get
into that a little later but um john was
a kid who went to harvard business
school and i was friends with his
girlfriend
and john was only remarkable to me and
that he was this most intense guy i'd
ever met
incredibly ambitious really intense one
of these guys whose hair is always
perfect and his suit is always perfect
he's you know he's got himself together
he's very you know
if you know hbs guys he looked like an
hbs guy
um basically i lost track of him and a
couple years later he called me up and
he invited me to ring the bell
to open the something called the merck
exchange to ring the morning bell
i had never heard of the merc exchange i
didn't know anything about oil i don't
know anything about the mark exchange i
knew it was in new york
but that was it so i went over to new
york and i got to this place and
it was that pit that you see in the
movie trading places
you know where people are going crazy
and yelling at each other so i basically
go in there and i stand up on this
little platform where there's
actually a bell um even though there's a
real electronic bell that actually rings
but you have a bell
and i look out and it's a sea of this
huge sea of guys mostly
tough tough guys from brooklyn mostly
italians and jews
who have apprenticed their way in and
these guys
they trade oil and basically it's the
biggest casino in the world
where these guys physically shove each
other push each other
they're fighting for territory in this
oil trading pit
because where you stand is actually
worth more money and there was actually
one old guy that i saw
who had hired he was a little guy and he
kept getting knocked out so he actually
hired three clerks so his entire job
was to hold him into the trading pit and
so when i saw this i thought this is
really interesting and i started
following these guys around
and it turns out that these trading
spots for the most part
are handed down like an apprenticeship
system and this
this trading floor used to be a potato
exchange then it was a dairy exchange
and now it's an oil exchange
but the families who run it were the
same guys from brooklyn who had been
trading potatoes
and trading milk and now they're trading
oil and it was really intense they're
all italians and jews from the same
streets in brooklyn
that actually my father grew up on which
is kind of cool and these guys make
fortunes and they're in their early
twenties they didn't go to college and
the exchange
ends every day at about two o'clock in
the afternoon so these guys make half a
million to a million bucks
by two in the afternoon and then they
just go spend it
so new york city becomes their entire
party zone and these guys aren't like
wall street guys who end up living on
park avenue or going to the hamptons
they literally still live on the same
block that they grew up in in brooklyn
they parked their ferrari right on the
curb and they basically buy up the
townhouse they grew up in and take over
all the floors and turn it into a palace
basically
so i thought it was really interesting
and i started following these guys
around
it turns out that johnny's story was
even more interesting i
i wanted to write another story about
crazy high rollers but what johnny had
done was pretty wild
at age 25 he had been made vice
president of this entire exchange
partially because his boss wanted to
stick it to one of the old traders
who didn't like change but partly
because johnny's a real brilliant
ambitious guy
he was a harvard business kid who was
also from brooklyn so he had sort of a
foot in two worlds
and as vice president of the exchange he
got invited to dubai
where he met a young muslim who
basically came up with the idea of
creating this exact same exchange
in dubai in the middle of the muslim
world so it would be the first real
capitalist market
in the middle of a place where there
really isn't anything like that and so
johnny started going back and forth to
dubai
a big part of this book is about dubai
and how crazy that world is i don't know
if any of you have been there but it's
basically the biggest amusement park in
the world now the the sheik who owns
dubai
is almost a trillionaire many billions
of dollars and he
realized that in the future they were
going to run out of oil at some point
so he decided to take all the oil money
he has now and turn his city into this
incredible
expat playground that is also the center
of the new arab world
and so he's invited so many financial
centers there that it's becoming
like new york like wall street and he's
also building all these things that you
see on 60 minutes around all these shows
there's the
biggest ski slope in the world it's an
indoor ski slope they're building a
biggest building in the world the
biggest hotel in the world they have two
of the biggest shopping malls the number
one of the number two biggest shopping
malls
they're building those islands that are
you can see from space they say i'm not
sure if that's really true
i actually heard a story that the emir
of dubai went to vancouver
and he liked vancouver so much that he
decided he's going to build vancouver
in the desert around dubai so they're
actually building vancouver out there
now
and it's just insane i mean the expats
outnumber the people who live there nine
to one now
so it's become this incredible expat
place and johnny realized that this was
sort of the next stop for oil
oil comes from this region anyways why
not put the exchange there
that exchange just opened this june the
book takes place a little while ago
where the idea was formed
he has to start traveling the world to
convince he's got to convince a bunch of
italians and jews
from brooklyn who didn't go to college
who are there right after 9 11
to partner with arabs and create an
exchange in dubai so it's a crazy
sort of story a thing that he attempted
and i don't want to give away i don't
know if
any of you read it yet or not it's only
been out a week or so but i don't want
to give it away but that's the story of
rigged
um i thought you know at this point i
would just open up to questions because
it's you know
a nice casual group and uh and if
anybody has anything they want to ask
about anything or
or the movie i guess i should tell you
so the movie we did film
right around here a lot of you probably
know that um the movie is called 21
that's of bringing down the house and
that comes out march
i believe march 28th now and it stars
kevin spacey as the professor who
trains the team of students lawrence
fishburne plays the bad guy who's uh
chasing them and kate bosworth is the
hot mit girl
and when i wrote the book there wasn't
really much of a love story in the book
but now in the movie there's much more
of a love story so um
it's uh it's it's i haven't seen it yet
but i've heard that it's fantastic and
uh you know i hope it is and it will
come out in march but
if there's any questions just go ahead
and uh raise your hand and i'll
call on you at this point anyway sure
i have a question that i'm prompted to
ask from reading ugly americans oh okay
i didn't even mention that one yeah
and um what i wondered is writing is
sort of a sedentary
occupation and you really describe
well i think the people that get an
adrenaline rush from
danger right and i just wondered how
how that how you were able to do it
right well i mean it's it's interesting
i kind of live
live a double life where i'm actually
scared of just about everything
and i'm uh you know very i'm a writer
and writers you know like the hole up in
their house with the lights off and
that's why i'm so pale as i never really
go outside but when i
when i start researching my stories i
become a part of the story
i never set out to be a journalist i set
out to
really follow a story and become one of
the guys i'm writing about so for
instance ugly americans takes place in
tokyo in this crazy expat world or
these guys become almost billionaires
trading stocks and taking advantage of a
bizarre market and
the main character falls in love with
the daughter of a japanese gangster
who he meets at a hostess club and it
goes from there so you can imagine it
gets a little wild
i went to tokyo i hung out with these
guys you know for a month or a few weeks
and i
i become a part of their i don't come in
with a notebook as if i'm going to write
their story
i come in and say i want to see what it
is that you're doing with bringing down
the house i mean i just strapped the
money to my body
and i flew to vegas and i started
joining the team with rigged i became a
part of this sort of group of people and
just hung out with them
so yeah i mean there is this you have to
sort of to capture what it is that
they're doing because i do i write about
adrenaline junkies i mean i write about
people who really get off on
getting into danger um busting vegas
some of you might have read
is about another mit kid i mean this
guy's had a gun pointed at him he's been
thrown out of a car he's had so many
crazy things happen to him
he's a really nice guy though if you
hung out with him you say oh he's you
know he's a really nice guy
but i'd like to get inside you know what
drives them to get into those positions
i myself am pretty
terrified most of the time i'm doing my
research i remember to do ugly americans
i had to interview a
yakuza crime boss in osaka and i got to
osaka and this group of guys
said um you're going to interview this
guy in this bar and he's going to be
sitting across from you and there's
going to be a table
of guys behind you and you're not
allowed to turn around and i get to this
bar and these guys are all covered in
tattoos and these are guys who like
cut off their pinky finger and give it
to their boss if they do something wrong
as a sign of respect
and i mean these are not the sopranos
these are some serious gangsters
and you you get in there and you're
doing this interview and there's a guy's
behind you you're not allowed to look at
what they're doing
and it's the worst experience i don't
even know what i asked this guy it's the
worst interview i've ever done i have no
idea
what went on but you just have to sort
of throw yourself into it and then see
what happens and then
and then i come back and i hole up in my
room and i write and i write and i write
so
you know there's just two parts of it
for me
anybody else sure
in both or all three of your movies uh
your books
um there were dollar figures the first
guys they made this amount of money
right the second one they made x amount
of money you didn't put money in there
yeah and this one yeah yeah it's
interesting
the traders on the trading floor who are
trading oil are making fortunes you know
a few hundred thousand dollars a day
kind of thing some of them are losing
fortunes too
but the main character of rigged
interestingly enough it wasn't about
money his story wasn't really about
making a fortune it was really about
trying to make this dubai thing happen
he didn't go into it to make money so i
didn't really focus
i mean you know they're partying their
ferraris there's lamborghinis there's
that whole side of the book
but his goal wasn't to go into oil and
make a killing on oil
um so that really wasn't the angle there
and uh you know it's yeah it's an
interesting question i mean it really in
all my other books you know there's
number figures of how much money is made
this story is more of an adventure story
i think it's definitely a departure for
me in that respect i mean
he didn't set out to to make 10 million
dollars in oil
and whether or not he did get rich off
of it i'm not even certain you know but
he was a part of creating you know
history in the oil world
and that's that's kind of what i was
writing about
there are i would think enormous
political ramifications from
being johnny d'agostino or creating a
merc
you know of a new merc in dubai
are the folks that are that you've hung
out with there or
who are playing that in that game are
they political people do they have a
sense of the politics
that are impacting them and that they're
impacting yeah i mean it's an it's a
really good question because
the people on the trading floor are
these incredible
you know gamblers essentially and they
don't have any real
thought about the rest of the world
about the fact that the price of oil is
going crazy about
people can't buy oil i mean what they're
thinking about
is okay a weather system is coming
towards new york how is that going to
affect the futures market in oil
or if some sheik shakes the hand of some
senator on tv how is that going to
affect the position i have right now in
crude
so they're really gamblers who think
about it specifically that way
there are of course huge issues involved
and creating sort of an exchange in
dubai
then you have to start thinking about
what is this going to mean to the world
you know is this going to change the
middle east in a good way or a bad way
is this going to
create peace or is it going to create
more war those questions come into that
aspect of it but in terms of the
traitors no and i got asked today on a
radio interview
i mean should i hate these people
because they're making all this money
off of the misery of oil in a lot of
ways
but no what they're doing is essentially
creating a secondary market
a uh a middleman market that really
it affects things but it doesn't drive
things it doesn't create the price of
oil
it sort of reacts to the price of oil
and yeah their bidding up and down does
affect it a little bit
but the reason that oil is at you know
almost 100 isn't because of them
the reason you know there are other
bigger reasons the differences between
97 and 99
might be because of them but not the
differences between 60 and 100.
so it's it's a good question i think
that these guys who trade oil know the
politics doesn't even
enter into their thought processes i
mean these guys are not that type of guy
um but in terms of the people who own
and run the exchanges
and the people in dubai who are creating
the exchanges they are thinking forward
to what it's going to bring to the
future yeah yeah
i was going to ask how much how much of
an influence did these men have
in the price of the price of oil yeah i
mean they are really you know the way
johnny explained it to me
is that they create sort of a liquidity
in that you can move all these future
barrels of oil
because they're there and because people
are buying and selling it and without
that everything sort of
grinds more to a halt because you can
only move what you have but i don't know
you know i'm not necessarily that you
know
knowledgeable and to be able to tell you
whether what they do is good or what
they do is bad
are these individuals friends it's it's
really a
closed system in that they apprentice
their way in so it's family almost i
mean you'll have a trader
who owns this spot on the exchange who
hires his cousin and then his cousin's
kid and then his
cousin's kid's friend and they really do
all know each other and they're all from
like two blocks in brooklyn
there are also traders who work for
major companies who are brought in
um but you know there's this division
and what i really focused on were these
sort of tough guy families who run a
large part of the exchange
these people who's storing your whose
story you're telling do you find that
what's their sort of motivation in
having you bring you in and let you tell
their story and ruin their lives
now with the mit kids they really the
way they thought of it
was that they had done this incredible
thing nobody knew anything about it
and it was like playing a professional
sport but no one had ever seen you play
it
so they kind of wanted people to know
their story but they didn't want their
names in it at first because they were
worried to be known as the kids who
played blackjack
you know because the book was well
received and not negatively received
suddenly now they want to take advantage
of that and they want to be a part of it
rigged was tricky and when i sat down to
write rig johnny said i don't want using
my name so i made up a name david russo
and the whole book
the character's name is david russo then
when i finished the book i gave it to
johnny and he read it and i said you
know
i'd really like you to write an
afterword that's more technical for some
people who might be interested in that
and i think you should put your real
name in it because this is kind of cool
the dubai exchange is really opening now
so why don't you just say who you are
and he thought about it and he said okay
you can use my name and the forward and
the afterward
so it's kind of a weird non-fiction book
in that the bulk of the book is written
with a fake
name and then his real name is in the
beginning and end and so he can do
interviews as well and tell people about
it
but it's tricky when ugly americans they
had a different experience where
didn't want me using his name wanted me
to disguise who he was i wrote the book
and then
cnn decided to try and figure out who he
was
um and the wall street journal a lot of
people uh sent you know reporters and
they found him and he got very upset
because he's
you know running away from the yakuza
and started a billion dollar hedge fund
he didn't want people to know who he was
so he called me up and said i want you
to erase me from your email list erase
me from your you know
phone pretend you never knew me and i
literally didn't see him for two years
and i was actually in the airport we
sold
ugly americans to dreamworks so we were
scouting locations in tokyo
and i was in the tokyo airport and he
was there and i said hey
we're making a movie he goes i know
everything about him just walked right
by
but he's actually called me in recent
weeks and said
i don't hate you i like you everything's
great i love the book uh you know
we're all fine we just don't you know
have a lot of interaction anymore
so you get different reactions i mean
it's definitely you know i've stayed
friends with all the mit kids i see them
they're always around you know and
they're fun guys
and johnny and i are friends and you
know with rigged and everything like
that but
you know you never know where the future
is going to go especially as a movie
comes out
it's such a bigger thing that you have
no idea what's going to happen after
that
so yeah
so this might be a little too early to
ask you've already done a book on hedge
funds
uh oil gambling what's the next product
what's the next book you know that's a
really good question uh
i've been working on a couple projects i
mean the movie is going to take up a lot
i'm going to be involved in touring and
we're going to put out a new paperback
you know with the movie so i'm going to
be involved through probably march on
that
i'm going to do another i have another
nonfiction story i'm working on right
now and it's about a kid from boston uh
but i don't really want to give away too
much but it's kind of about what the new
american dream
is because i think the american dream
has changed dramatically in the last 20
years
and uh my parents american dream is very
different than my friends american dream
and it's kind of about that so it kind
of intersects with all the stuff i've
written
but um yeah i don't want to give it away
it's going to be another one of my
stories though
did the people in mit still go to um
to vegas and second of all did the irs
become involved with them
shortly after the book was the irs
became involved actually before the book
came out these guys were audited
a couple times um and they because you
declare your
your winnings in that other category and
when you have two million dollars in the
other category people start to wonder
what's going on
so they you know they didn't do anything
illegal these guys they were really very
careful about the irs because they
didn't that's where you go down
um the the kids at mit still do this
they're still an mit blackjack team
one of the kids from bringing on the
house is involved as a teacher to them
and uh i spoke at mit just a month ago
about something you know and
this kid came up to me and said that
they had actually figured out how to
crack uh
some of the mass state uh scratch
tickets because one of the scratch
tickets it turns out
as the money gets bigger and bigger
there comes a point when buying a
certain amount becomes
mathematically advantageous so they put
together six hundred thousand dollars
in investment money and they were buying
it and they had made a million and a
quarter
in a period of a year so i don't i'm
probably ruining their scheme right now
but they said they were pretty much done
with it
um but you know mit kids they keep keep
coming up with it it's not just mit i
know caltech has a team
uh that plays blackjack there's an
australian team there's a european team
i don't know if there's a bu team um i
don't know a lot of kids in the math
department at bu but
it's possible i mean a lot of college
kids do it and it's funny because i go
to vegas a lot
and you will see kids using the system
you'll you'll notice kids you know
signaling each other in the hat and like
calling each other in and out
and i guarantee you 90 of them are
really bad at it and that's the funny
thing i've been there with jeff
the main character and he's looking
around and goes oh that guy's bad he's
gonna get killed and
it's it's really funny to watch but if
you go on a crazy weekend like a fourth
of july weekend
to the bellagio i guarantee you'll see
one or two kids trying it out
okay has there been a story that
somebody's approached you
to tell and you said no way oh yeah
there's been plenty of those there was
one group of
kids who wanted to hit uh the moscow
casino
and i said there's no way i want
anything to do with that you get caught
there and that's your own problem and
then uh
i i mean i get the weirdest phone calls
i got a call a guy who called me up
and uh he said that he knew where the
fog art museum art was knew where
not the fog the um sorry the gardner
museum that he he was involved
and i was like no you don't and i
started to sort of check up on him and
he had just been released from 12 years
in prison
for robbing a museum in the exact same
way that that museum had been robbed
down to every detail so i started
thinking okay maybe he does know and so
i call him back and he's
he's you know he makes me call him at
pay phones it was that kind of thing
and he said i want to meet you i'm i'm
on parole so i'm not allowed out of
california but i'm going to meet you in
south boston and he named some ally
and i'm like you know what i'm not going
that direction
i mean another writer probably would
have but i stopped there and then i got
a call
i got a email from someone in china who
said that he had found the world's
largest brothel
and that it was a sheraton hotel and
that every room had a different woman in
it
but i wasn't gonna go out there and
research that one i get these questions
all the time i mean they're pretty crazy
and i actually keep a phone uh that's
listed
but there's no phone attached to it at
the end of each week i check all the
messages to see
what crazy stories there are and every
now and then there's a good story but 99
of them are
you know you just can't follow up on
them
you just mention china right i mean
that's a big game right now
yeah it's a big bubble right now
different kind of
system of justice you know right there's
no irs but there's a lot of this right
uh anybody approach you about doing a
story about the big game in china well i
mean i
you know china is an interesting area
and i've definitely been approached with
different stories that take place all
over there
in the just the casino world i mean what
they've done with macau is just
out of control it's twice the size of
vegas and it's you know
they're building hotels the largest
hotels the largest casinos in the world
that's going to be much much bigger than
vegas
but i haven't really found an angle i
mean my stories all are really in
america american stories with american
characters
um so i haven't really found the story i
want to do there was a murder in hong
kong that i thought about
talking about that actually it's uh
mcginnis is doing just did a book on it
i think um
but i don't do crime really you know
it's not
any stock market oh this giant stock
market the chinese yeah i mean i'm sure
there's a great story there i just uh
i i probably won't but maybe one day
yeah yeah
anybody else well i just want to thank
you all i'm going to sign whatever you
want me to sign and i hope you all
enjoyed it and thanks so much